hello everybody how's it going hope
every you all enjoyed the
uh beautiful games happening at us
championship
i'm very glad to see charissa win it and
so wesley of course
that was actually not what i had
expected i know karissa would be top
three but i kind of thought nazi would
win so i i'm glad i didn't really put
any bets on that
um
so today we're going to kind of continue
with what we were talking about before
us championship which was tall of course
i really had this few
puzzles on him
that are truly beautiful and i just
wanted to go over them
and from this next week we'll
look at another world champion or
opening we're gonna have a poll about
that and of course if you haven't
already please take a quick look and
consider
well
getting my book
i'm still waiting on it i know it'll be
here this week so next time i should
have a copy of it showing like this but
imagine this book right here
yeah well thank you for everybody for
being here and
let's just get to it
so
we are gonna look
at
this game which was between one and only
keras
went
tall the last move for white was rook to
b2
now what do you think is going on here
maybe let's talk about this position a
little
the main question that we should answer
is
should they be exchanging that's rook
because white is offering a rook
trade
and we would go into
opposite colored bishops and i've
actually recently had a student who for
the life of me i can't remember fool
because
i actually recently started having more
than like 30 40 students and oh my god
but i had a student recently who was
telling me about it was like maybe two
weeks ago he was talking about
why should we like um how can we win um
opposite colored bishops like is that if
the like should we keep the rook should
we exchange the rooks or some of the
specific circumstances so this would be
good for him i know it was a he
that's the only thing i remember i
apologize it wasn't me i i
assumed because you would have said
something earlier hopefully
all right so
how do you um
guys and
gals i guess
think
what do you think shall we go ahead and
schedule a rook exchange
we got a rook trade
or no
okay we have a
i think we have a
morris smashley so not morris ashley so
there's a fake maurice in the chat
who wants to keep the rook
we have somebody who wants to play
bishop before good god
it's very amazing so many people are
saying no to exchange
you'd say no to
all right
he says i don't know
okay
um
i mean intuitively i wouldn't
fair point
i mean exchanging brooks especially in
opposite colored bishops even though he
would have an extra pawn is a little
scary because we've all heard the
stories about how somebody got stuck
with an extra pawn and the opposite
colored bishop and they couldn't win it
and how it was so painful i'm not
talking from experience you know never
happened to me
kidding
um so it's obviously a good idea to keep
in mind
that aspect of it but
this is a specific situation because our
king is also active
and it's not just
one pawn that we would have extra
exactly as
just us is saying in the chat
if we were to do this trade
we could actually pick up another pawn
for this reason i support this exchange
even if opponent tries to activate their
bishops
not good enough because our king becomes
extremely active
and now we have the
that is a pass pawn and we also have
possibilities with our h-pawn and we
have a lot of possibilities with our
active king and active bishop so because
we have a bunch of different points of
advantage the rook exchange back few
moves ago
good idea and as you can guess it tall
did go for it he ended up in this
position push stitch five and now
he did a truly amazing move which i
apologize for the in-person audience
because i can't hide but
sorry guys
as i truly apologize i still have not
figured out how to
hide that aspect of leeches on it
sorry
yes
i have a b5 in the chat i have a
the sack the bishop i think i have an f4
well there's a f5 i'm assuming that's
supposed to be f4 or
b5 second it's interesting i
kind of want to play
bishop e5 just to
say
your chapter oh the king
i mean
yeah and the other problem is that if by
some miracle opponent could do this
that would be painful let's say if you
play f4 and somehow opponents can get
this bishop here that'll be yes right
oops
right that would be kind of fun i mean
it's it's truly
a miracle if opponents can do it but why
would i give that chance you know
so
now i guess the main question is should
we go
uh
should we go do the sacrifice or should
we take a chill and go like b5
to be fair i think
b5 is fine
just to clarify i mean i don't have
anything against b5 or h4 or f4 for that
matter
but
which one do you think is the strongest
and while we do that i'm gonna
open this with hopes of redbull
sponsoring me
oh [ __ ] that's true
it's not gonna happen but
still
it's funny i i used to watch how i met
your mother and then later on i realized
that one of the main characters kept
drinking red bull they danced they drank
so much of it without like a sponsorship
that's i think rhett will like gave them
a like lifetime supply or something
because how much they promoted it just
because they liked it so
i don't think yeah i'm not really
looking for a lifetime
supply i think my kidneys wouldn't be
able to handle it but
still
quite personally i will push me fire i
will push my pawn yeah so to be fair
pushing pawns off actually any of the
pawns that is that is fine
but
of course you're watching a tall game
so that was kind of a giveaway
and the the technical reason behind it
is that you are going to
simply you have
too many points of advantage you have a
passport on b5 a passport on h4 you have
the possibility of eating the e5 pawn
you have another pass spawn on f4
seriously what else do you want
so
how can black try to well how can white
try to stop this
king g one only move and we can simply
be like all right you wanna deal with
that aspect of it sure now that your
king is going to be playing
mouse with my pawn on h3 i'm gonna
simply bring the king pick up this guy
push my pawn
if you manage to exchange your bishop
with my pawn which is very likely
because this pawns this pawn structure
this pawn end game will be truly
winning
so
one of the good things to consider doing
is if you don't feel comfortable with
your opponent games make sure to
pick up a book i would recommend the
devorsky book the pawn games on that are
truly all you need to know you're more
than welcome to reduce any other
resources
but
um
you don't necessarily need to know every
single theoretical end game but you
gotta know your opponent games because
again right now you have advantage but
if you don't know that's only these
pawns remaining is winning or you can't
convert that advantage in a winning
pawns game
that's kind of about it
yeah that'll be painful
yeah the wretsky the word ski end game
he has a like a ginormous book which is
very pretty
whoops
all right
this one
i actually have bad news for us let me
actually flip the board again
we're gonna be looking at this from
white and tall actually
made a horror horrible weight i don't
wanna say horrible but made a mistake
he went for queen d1
and
yeah what do you think white should do
tall ended up losing this game
thank you
so how are you feeling
somebody oh that was the
conversation about dreddle well okay
maybe let's start thinking about this if
you were to push this pawn turn it into
a queen as white
what would black do maybe let's
i think that's the first thing you
should consider
okay
queen f3
um let's say king goes to
h3 then what would you do
yeah
that will be a painful check king has to
go up
checkmate in one
well that's not checkmating one but
that's another checkmate coming up i
think the easiest one is just queen g3
checkmate
yeah so if you were to make this queen
not a good idea because check if you go
up it's even worse because you
self-checkmate
so now after this check the king gotta
probably come down
either way and black would easily have
perpetual and tom would have saved this
game
however
whoops let's go back ah go back
okay so
right now promoting doesn't work even
though we would get two queens beautiful
right but it wouldn't work because of
what we just saw so how do you think
white can continue
i see the chat is kind of mentioning
queen takes d6 but question mark so give
me more don't just give me one move so
if queen takes d6
um
what if opponents does queen f3 can they
still do the check check check will it
still be a draw
i used to have this issue when i was
doing summer camps
my kids would only give me one movers
yeah i was looking at that but
then
i mean like we could
block we could block with our queen on
on g3 but then they push
f1 queen wait wait what are you oh
you're thinking about queen takes dc's
queen f3 and then king h3
ah so then you were thinking about like
pawn takes on f2
but that's i wouldn't go king history
it's too scary
yeah because there's no more queen d1
oh there's no perpetual
oh thank you eric giving me bigger lines
so queen d6 queen takes d6 queen f3
check king g1 no queen d1 i agree so
since thank you moda since um and isaac
since queen takes d6 there will be no
more perpetual for black queen takes d6
is suddenly becoming a more interesting
candidate so queen takes d6 queen takes
d6
let's say we continue and
beautifully do manage to make a queen
is there anything that worries us here
to be fair black still does have two
pawns for a bishop
but
um
caffener there will be twitch today in
about
i want to say 40 minutes or so we are
gonna have a switch to twitch and
analyze your game so if you guys have
any games ready that you've played over
the week or before that or you're
playing right now
feel free to have a link from leeches
ready for us and join us on twitch in
about
40 45 minutes and we'll analyze your
games
so is this winning are we happy with
this
yeah i would have i wouldn't call this
winning per se
but
it is also
it's advantageous because black can take
over here
we can still throw in the check and we
can pick this up and this will fall too
it's still hard to
like for me winning is like when i can
actually feel like i don't i don't have
much
um danger on me but because a pond still
has that like pond that i need to take
care of and i have so little material i
wouldn't call it winning just yet but
yes advantageous yeah good enough for us
good enough for tall to
feel slightly tortured oops okay
uh how about this one this one let's
look at it from white's perspective todd
was white in this game black took over
here now
let's do
an evaluation in this position
who is better
just because it's tall it doesn't mean
he's gonna win as we saw in the previous
game he did not win
so
i keep closing off the product
the logo there we go much better
okay somebody says black king is safer
tall thinks differently as long as he
has a tempo he doesn't care if he's in
danger i mean you're not wrong
you prefer black why
why specifically and i learned to ask a
specific i learned to kind of push
boundaries and ask more specific
questions from my students
because i have a professor
he's really nice but he kind of like
whenever i i like presents like an
argument or like a
sentence he always goes deeper and he
always makes me think
my head sometimes hurts after class or
when we have a discussion but still he
kind of just whenever like i feel like
okay this is the end of it he pushes it
a little farther he pushes it a little
farther and i do have a midterm
take-home exam to finish for that class
by midnight i still have a few questions
to type in so
wish me luck
yeah
i'm halfway there but
forming my thoughts into paragraphs are
much harder than i remember
all right so back to chess try to push
your boundaries specifically why
okay white has more activity so i feel
like white would be better as long as
his king doesn't get attacked
eric i think you're thinking too
um
i don't want to say superficial but i
don't have a better word sorry
i'm sure there's a better word to
describe what i'm thinking but that's
the first thing that comes to mind
um
maybe think specifically not just the
psychological aspect of how you feel
about the position and how you think
about the position but chest wise what
does black want
black just took one of one of our pieces
so now they're threatening
two of our pieces i know it hurts both
of my bishops are under attack and my
king is a little you know but we can
also take that bishop exactly so i have
so many things are just up in the air
because we're of where our king is right
now okay but i guess we could maybe it
would be fine to move it over later and
use the dark square bishop to defend
fair point um
i wish we could save the light squared
bishop and keep a decent position but if
we see save the light square bishop then
opponents will take over here and i
don't want to deal with that pawn right
yeah
um
so the move that we'll do is gonna be
something about this pawn so we're gonna
take that let's talk about what if we
take it to the pawn if we take it to the
pond now black actually has a serious
threat
now maybe you can tell me what do you
think black can do right now
i also feel a sneeze coming i apologize
for what you might hear
well yeah if it happens i'll make sure
to hold the microphone but
it's that loose weather has been going
crazy it starts off like really cold
that morning so i have to wear like
three layers when i go out by the time
the sun comes up and
around noon it gets so hot that i need
to just take everything off at that
point and then when it again gets to
this like the sun goes away it gets
again super cool so i have to always
carry like three different layers with
me
okay yeah white does have activity but
they're all loose yeah i agree with that
too
ah thank you moda that is the exact move
that i was hoping someone to tell yeah
bishop d6
attacking my rook saving their own
bishop
and now this guy is also under attack
even if i start to construct an attack
they can hit there even if i take that
uh oh battery
i need this to be plugged in from
somewhere
it's giving me alarm
but yes
check
you gotta move another check and bye bye
rook
might be hard to see i agree
but um at the same time
i wouldn't
put it past black because we are giving
opponent too many loose things to attack
and because your king is just so open
it's a problem
so let's talk about bishop takes c3
take
now should we exchange queens and while
you think about that i'm going to figure
out
why isn't this beautiful
oh wait now it's working
no it's not
okay i think it was just loose
no
or it needed your touch
all right
battery problems are saved that's good
yeah
i mean technically we kind of do have a
choice we can try to play maybe queen of
four but i don't really want to
deal with that choice honestly
there's that there's that
yeah
yeah we gotta
and then we will pick up the bishop that
we just lost
and this position is fine but
unfortunately opponents will get the
chance to
pick up some of our pawns and
this could be a safe draw i don't really
think there is going to be
much that tall can do in this position
honestly
yeah
even when you're tall you're gonna
come in short yeah you stole it down
there i was gonna say you're gonna come
shorthand
it's all right
huh i couldn't help myself i understand
it's all right
all right
let's look at a different one again
we're gonna watch tall get whooped
maybe i should have changed the
title up
not the amazing top
yeah
so
black's final move tall's final move was
to play e2
this feels just
off
can you say why
i'm gonna close that through the timing
ah thank you
bach ken
are you persian or are you google
translating i think we've had this
conversation before because i'm getting
in touch with this google translate
let's type in english
which one is the princess i mean the way
you're typing i want to say you but
what is that emoji
i truly have fun when i stream
because most of the time i'm with
students so it's a one-on-one
i can't
get as engaged
too many opinions or i'm with my cats
and he's the boss of me so i don't
really get in
saying anything
but i'll i'll give you guys one or two
cat stories that has been happening
recently yeah okay so i see okay okay we
got good chess left going now we got
somebody's looking out for checks good
job so bishop b3
also thank you eric you mentioned it
first
king god i mean uh if the king moves
well bishop she said that's about it
yeah
this one was easy and i truly don't
understand how tall just missed it
i guess he came short again
now this one was truly easy i don't
understand how could a tall could have
missed it but even if not e2 the
position is still uh very unpleasant
black would have to take we take and
they have like
maybe rook e7 but then this will this
takes doesn't work clearly so
yeah
fair point
i guess we it would be easier if we saw
the whole game before we started
um
judging tall but this is a truly
beautiful tacky game
maybe a t maybe a lesson the take home
lesson could be
the f7
the the f7 pawn
because if there was a pawn on f7 i
don't think it would have been
um
this problematic huh
all right
let's keep going now white is time on
off finally we're gonna see one that
tall wins
all right so
um
i wanna
i'm gonna go ahead and uh
give you a little fruit for thought
white played b5 which was horrible but
before we address why it was horrible i
want you guys to think
if it was um
if um
mark taimanov wanted to actually play
the correct move what would be the
correct move
it's a little hard so don't feel too
too beat but let's let's give it like
maybe a minute or two minutes
yeah we're remember sorry guys please
keep in mind we are trying to think
about
white in the real game played b5 which
was a bad move
we are trying to think what would be the
best move for white
because in the chat somebody said bishop
g4 i'm not opposed to it but that wasn't
the question and it's not black's turn
right now
so make sure to consider the move for
white
ooh
bukura you
mo you might be onto something
yeah keep thinking about it and while
you do i'll give you a little
cat story since
another cat lover walked in
um
so there's some there are like two three
stray cats that come behind my my in my
patio almost ex every night one of them
has been coming for over a year
one of them started to come recently
the orange one is so
vocal it just does not stop meowing when
it comes over and it gets peachy all
riled up and peachy meals and they just
sing together for like two hours every
night at like midnight
so
i fed it i made sure it has food and
water and i went to bed and fishy
stopped singing and then like after half
hour i started hearing like
little like knocks on the window and i
was like jesus christ who is it at like
two in the morning
and
guess what
the
the orange cat the white cat the new one
has recently
developed a new thing
when peachy is on his cat tree next to
the window
the other cat sits on the chair that i
have outside and knocks with the with
his paws to the window to pc and then
peachy knocks back behind the window so
they were like kind of playing with
their hands behind it it was kind of a
romeo and julius situation
but i guess in this situation the juliet
was the one
behind the wind like outside the window
and romeo my cat i guess the male one
was
still
back so that was my little cat story
that they don't let me sleep until two
in the morning so i have to come up with
something new but okay
enough about kitties
i agree
i see a lot of knight g5s and you are
correct knight g5 would be the deadly
move that's tall would have probably
been
at least uncomfortable about because you
kind of got to take it but when you take
it bishop takes g5 they eat a pawn
they're attacking your rook if you move
the stroke your bishop drops if you move
the bishop your rook drops
oh good god this is just
oh yeah
i don't know what to think about this
all right yeah this is just horrific to
look at
yeah i mean just push c5 and yeah you
can maybe try to offer a queen exchange
but how do you plan to activate your
pieces
yeah
all right
um hopefully that face that i made will
not be the thumbnail because
i think that will be a lot of fun
i've had some weird faces that made it
to the thumbnail so
yeah
okay question why can't black play king
g8 after knight g5 well
do you want to answer that yourself
i'll give you guys a second
okay maybe not the second per se but
let's say 30 seconds
what's the first thing in chess we want
to
look for
thank you i usually whenever i'm working
with students i usually say um what's
the first thing we want to look for we
want to check for in chess and they're
like oh well checks so
i tried to throw in a little hint of the
question but yeah exactly so looking for
checks boom
voila
and oh this would be fun smother
checkmate huh
it's been a it's been such a long time
since i've actually managed to do a
successful smother checkmate even in my
online games people just don't let me
i know they just don't let me it's just
so hurtful i'm starting to take it
personal
they never resign until
the point where you have a really nice
checkpoint i know right
i have this beautiful pawn check mate
and this guy like continued for like
50 moves and i had like an extra piece
and it was dreadful and i wanted to just
end the game but it was a 10 minute game
so it wasn't ending and as soon as i had
a pawn checkmate they resigned it was
just sad
all right
i see somebody's computer is glitching
or
is it time for a little by by time
all right
i'm gonna assume it's a glitch rather
than
ask to get
banned ah well happens to everybody well
not everybody but anyways so
white had this beautiful tactic but
white missed it and paid quite dearly
for it
they went for b5
now
it's so chess is just one of those games
that is so
weirdly amazing
how you can
just um
how you can just
the tables just turn immediately and
right now i'm actually thinking about it
you know one of those like squiggly
tables that literally turns
but yeah so i would um
so now the tables did turn because white
missed this chance
oh my god eric beautiful beautifully
done
walking right into discovery thank you
to sue
oh my god i'm so sorry tusupu kura i've
seen you
multiple times in my chat and i still
have trouble pronunciating it's not on
you it's on me i just can't pronounce it
for the life of me
but okay
yep
it's important i think take this rook
first i'm sure this is not
a bad idea wait actually let me retract
that comment because we're not
doing it right we're not attacking
anything on d1 anymore
so it was actually a bad idea i
apologize for the
i didn't say that did i
yeah so always important to make sure we
think about checks tempo guys tempo make
sure you are using all of your tools
make sure you're doing everything
as
okay that came off wrong i was gonna say
as hurtful as possible for the opponent
i don't think that's the ethical thing
and i am doing a healthcare ethics minor
i don't think my ethics professor would
be happy about that
okay um
let's go with the knowing let's let's
make sure that you are using all of your
um tools such as discoveries pins all
those you're utilizing your attack
correctly
oh i've said this story multiple times
when i when i were initially when i
wanted to
teach at the chess club weekly lesson
the first thing that i wanted to title
the class was how to play chess
unknowingly and then the club managers
were like
maybe a little user-friendly
and so we landed on chess and psychology
but the theme is still the same
i want to teach you how to play that no
chess unknowingly not to specifically
know your opponent per se
but to just
you know
play just beautifully oh that would be a
better
marketing
anyways
oh my god
all right let's look at a different tall
game he actually does win this one
surprise surprise
so opponent's last move was to take
queen takes e4 this should be a really
easy one so let's just get this one out
out of the way really quickly
we can do this
and while we're doing that i'm gonna
actually check the youtube from my end
because i actually haven't been able to
see our stream yet
i'm always so afraid that my youtube is
just gonna have a weird noise coming
popping out left and right and
oh
no sound yes
oh i like the thumbnail all right
it was funny i was talking to um our
video department yeah thank you i was
talking to our video department and we
kind of noticed that um some of the
streams and thumbnails when my face is
not on it that doesn't get as many views
and
but like this is such a cool thumbnail
why wouldn't people want to watch this
it's like a tall standing like this like
booms
right but i was i was a little um
shocked to see that it wasn't getting as
much views anyways this was an easy win
for tall you know we look at some hard
ones we look at some easy ones it
balances out eventually right
hopefully all right
thank you zachary yeah that's what i'm
saying the thumbnail
is truly
um powerful in the streaming
um
i want to say aero but i don't know if
that's the right string business that
sounds weird anyways so in this one
very interestingly
tall is playing as black
white made a mistake white played king
f2 this was a mistake can you think of
what would be a good ah
bad mouse hopefully nobody saw it
yeah can you think what would be a good
move for white
yeah
kind of showed unfortunately it was too
fast but
hey
yeah
sorry guys that was analysis fault
badmouth
all right
so
the threat is
the threat is clear right we want to eat
this bishop
upon a white king is weak so for white
it would be reasonable to want to defend
this bishop or to put the king in a safe
spot
now
castling would be actually truly um
cool
because now there's this really cool
knight c2 then pick up this guy i think
this is possibly why
maybe knight c2 was missed but like this
is just screaming discovery attack so i
don't know why i missed why white missed
this
but it gave us something to talk about
right so i uh yeah king f2 is a little
weird now what do you think we can do
after king f2
um ben is saying i wish my mouse made
such good mouse slips mine just blunders
queens
fair points i've had a little issues
back and forth with this mouse
it doesn't hurt me but it helps the
viewers and that's um
i mean makes it the fun i guess but
yeah i wish peachy would be able to
teach this mouse
how to behave but
oh zachary i like that idea ben
bachan i think that's also a possibility
thank you ayman i think you're also kind
of considering moda yeah
but give me more so what if rook takes
e3 king takes e3 then what do you do oh
thank you webster you just answered my
question
knight's g4 so what if um
what do you want to do after knight g4
oh somebody is smelling blood oh good
god we have a vampire in the chat
so knight glory first isn't good
uh 94 first i think it's the
transposition but after take if you take
because they don't have to take it it
kind of gives white a little chance to
like fight back
and stop your queen d4 ideas i didn't
consider that i was just looking at
checks after this no that's okay you
should always look out for checks
knight's g4 if we take and we give this
check this doesn't work the knight just
blocks it
taking is a maybe but because opponents
still can do some blockages like this i
don't really like that
but if we start with rookie three ah
king takes now we can do this check
and if they take now what do we do
maybe give me a two mover because i feel
like the first move is very easy
so you want to do queen d4 first and
then bishop g4
yeah yeah but i do have a
follow-up question what if queen d4 what
if queen d4
king goes to e2 do you still want to
take over here
okay if you take that's still fine
king moves and then we'll just bring in
the rope yeah
simple enough
yeah
we yeah we're using every single piece
exactly with tempo good job yeah
so
um opponent here i mean this didn't
really happen in the game because they
didn't take but now king e2 would make
more sense but again this would still
fall and this would be actually a little
unclear so white
did actually have the opportunity to
take here
and the reason is that as we said if
white did the long castle here this is
like plus five
so white completely blew a winning
advantage away by playing king f2 but
white just blew up the advantage of
weight the white didn't completely turn
the tables
so white gave black some chance and now
okay to be fair now white blew it
completely
so white went from a winning position to
a possibility for
um
some unclearness and then
so now what do we do
don't forget to do scans or checks all
the time
thank you
yep
they could take it and if they do
now
i'm sorry what i was gonna say you can't
check them with the queen because they
take your work you're gonna move your
book you have to or
you have half you have the first part of
it correct the first half of it that we
can't give a shake because our rook is
on the attack we don't have to move the
rook
the but the move that we do should be
related to the rook we can defend it we
can move it you know
exactly
now we're defending the rook while we
pick up a piece
exactly thank you zachary a lot of nasty
discoveries i agree
oh did i do something to the stream
i don't think so let me see
i don't think i did anything
no what's wrong i don't know i saw it in
the chat somebody said fix this dream ah
nothing was wrong
all right
beautiful oh
it's his issue forget about it all right
sure
so
bishop takes d4 black is completely
winning now because
as stated earlier a lot of nasty
discoveries i quote knife take we simply
take
and kaboom now what do we do
oh this is so beautiful
i just want to hug this game but i can't
thank you thank you um
para psychic
took me a second to read this jesus
aha double check there we go
to be fair you could just play queen f4
check two but double check even better
take boom
move boom
i'm running out of booms all right and
finally what do we do now
one more boom thank you
that'll do
yeah
nice
and if they take it now okay one more
boom
but that's that's the end of the booms i
mean there are more booms to follow but
they're they're tiny booms
all right oh there's a question is
rookie 2 better than rook f3 alright
let's go address that
if i can get this mouse to cooperate
rook f3 ah
king no i think it's the same but the
only thing is since the king is not on
e2 anymore i can't give this check
so i would just have to sacrifice even
more but i just really wanted to get my
work involved but this is also winning
just you're just going to make it a
little harder on yourself
yeah
does that make sense
like you used you can't really use your
rook right now anymore like
the engine is suggesting this
and i don't know how i feel about it
because it's such a
not check and not threatening move i
mean technically there is a threat so i
can't say non-threatening move but i i
don't know i don't i don't
i feel more comfortable with something
that i can immediately see and i know
exactly what my opponent is going to do
such as the force will move rookie 2
boom boom
check
boom i'm more happy with this
yeah i don't know if i if in the real
game if in time trouble you would find
h6 so
all right let's move it along
ready for another next one
yeah thank you thank you
all right we got
a boring game
i was i was hopeful for a second
all right let me ask you right now black
played g3
how is this
what do you think
is going on here anyone better anyone
worse well i mean if somebody is better
by definition the other person is worse
so i guess
i walked into that over all that one huh
conda thank you thank you
my cat is not here now but
he really i should i mean theoretically
he he can't go here he can't come here
because he is emotional support animal
registered on everything he has a little
car too
but
i don't know how he would behave
he started being a little um
too playful and sometimes he tries to
play with my laptop battery cord and i
do not appreciate that and there are too
many cords here for a cat to
you know
mess with
so someone is saying white is better
okay
more than someone is some some people
are saying white is better
but
i don't know
because
yeah f2 coming up
yeah black has a lot of threats you kind
of got to take it
and oops the other option was to take
here take that rook c1
but this now is uh you know now black is
better because first things first i can
pick up this pawn and then that pawn
so it was very important to whoa whoa
what happened here wrong wrong way with
the mouse okay it was very important to
decide all right
i'm gonna cut my losses i'm gonna do
this
i'm gonna go attack here
even if you take it
now this this is a draw because your
king isn't stuck you can't advance your
position doesn't matter to it doesn't
matter if you could take this then you
would be able to push your palms you
haven't taken it you can't push your
pawns this would be draw so it's
important to kind of realize when to
attack when to not right now this would
be like a tacky move
but realizing that that does not work
and we need to retreat and we need to
reevaluate the position and we should
take take and just go ahead and get rid
of this pawn
was the key for this position and yes
you are right trick after it does look
scary we shouldn't allow it to happen
that easily
yeah
all right whoops wrong way
white to move
white is tall
black's final move was queen d7 which
was a horrible mistake
only if black played queen c7 black was
actually able to hold surprisingly i
don't know how but
black made a mistake and played queen to
d7
now
one thing to consider since i've already
given you a small hint that if blue
black put the queen on c7 black would be
able to hold
at least prolong the game maybe let's go
with that
um
what do you think is a big difference
between
um
opportunities for the queen on c7 or on
d7
and while you're at it don't forget to
tell me what should whites do to
okay i'm getting the f6 oh welcome back
back in
dark square control possibly
dislodging the white queen i like that
b6 square i like that too
so
the diagonal yeah that's fair too i
think when d7's main purpose was to
attack this but that also kind of just
pushes us to then you know that because
my pawn is under attack now this pushes
me to want to play f6
now let's go one move back if the queen
went to c7 and we played f6 now what do
you think black should have done
okay i like that f6 is not forced i
agree but what if you play f6 regardless
ah there we go mother queen e5
attacking this guy
centralizing the queen attacking this
one that one even if you played f7 king
g7 now black is actually better
how do you plan to stop this attack
how do you plan to stop
uh how do you plan to include your queen
in the game opponent has an extra bishop
right
exactly good job so that's why queen c7
would be better but now even if you do
queen g4 it does not work anymore
because we do this check
and because the queen is no longer on e5
it's not
this attack on h5 is not as strong and
we can easily stop it
we can easily defend the h5
i'm just going to leave it up to you how
can we defend the h5
three two one go
exactly i'll translate that into queen
c5
nice even check just key moves and now
we actually have serious checkmate
threats too
yeah
easy peasy
i have a kid who i had a kid today who
whenever i ask him a question and his
obvious question always is easy peace
is he so cute
yeah his father is persian so he sits in
and then we like do multi-language so
like when i'm talking like talk talk
like normal talk i talk in farsi when
i'm talking chess
i talk in english and he actually
responds very well yeah i like him he's
a cutie pie
he has really big eyes it's funny
all right um this one tall was actually
black
and as you can imagine
white is
you know
a little bit better you know a few ponds
more
nothing big deal not a big deal huh
but how do you think
how do you think we can possibly set a
trap for white this one is a little
weird but let's let's kind of maybe uh
keep an eye on the goal if you could
make it draw that would be nice huh so
can we try to maybe set a trap to
achieve that goal
hook mate straight hook what hook mate
threats well if rookie 2 what if king
goes to d3 king on d3 would be attacking
your g4 pawn
rookie one whoa whoa three brooks
is there still
changing five first i mean i if you play
kingdom five i think i would just play
rook d7 check
or i can just play bishop d3 and let it
be
good luck
knight b1 could be fishy
well knight b1 what if king d3
knight e4 i mean i would take it
probably you take that ah
i could take or i could just play king
d3 again it's like this
you guys just
underestimate
the hunger for pawn huh
you're looking for something to
sacrifice
i don't think you've got much left to
sacrifice
you shouldn't be sacrificing a rooker at
night let me put it that way
you lose them
that's it
who is getting forked where now
so in a lot of the lines that i see and
we're talking about king d3 seems to be
problematic huh
how is your night going to e3
does pawn to d3 yeah you lose your
knight
ah there you go now you're thinking
critically how do we stop the king from
going to d3
i like that we're getting somewhere
just a heads up this will be our last
puzzle
i like talking about tall but
we got some
viewers game to look at
ah rook e3 i like that it's rookie three
now let's talk if rookie three what if
rook takes g7
what do we do now
okay it might be one two moves to
consider king d1 king c1 maybe let's
start with king c1 if the king goes to
c1 then what do you do
exactly
if king goes to c1
that's actually horrible wait actually
maybe not horrible
but now you are again threatening to do
the same perpetual
can't be stopped
horrible was not the right choice of
word but
yeah and if the king goes to d1 boom
check king there boom check
king here would be fun huh
but i don't think that would be
realistic to hope for but we can't
easily hope for a draw so it's very very
important to set your expectations based
on
the position you should do the move that
the position needs you should always
prioritize what
what's going on right now in the
position in front of you not who your
opponent is how you think you should
play how you wish you could play
there's so much psychology in chess and
it's truly fun um i have a psychology
professor right now who actually told me
that
because he used to play chess as a kid
he became interested in psychology i
don't think he plays chess anymore which
is sad
but
still
so yeah
um
it was a pleasure being here don't
forget we're gonna do switch to twitch
in about probably 10 minutes or less we
will see you on twitch with your games
to analyze and leech us
and
thank you everybody
[Music]
you